j'aimerais qu'on parle du nichon gates
que s'est il réellement passé et une
séquence qui a fait exploser les réseaux
sociaux pendant la cérémonie il a eu ce
qu'on appelle dans le milieu un nichon
gates et milieu du volley je vous jure
que c'est vrai c'est tf1 en effet montré
des miss qui était dénudé vous savez
qu'on ne rentre pas là dedans quand les
gens parlent été annoncée de caméraman
qui a séduit voir des poitrines
mais il faut se calmer je vais te dire 1
1 pour servir les acteurs excusé ah
ouais mais tf1 s'est excusé bah oui momo
sissoko m'excuser alors non ce n'était
pas dans les habitudes quand même où il
va regarder ce qui s'est passé moi ça
m'a aidé c'est le poil mais mariage
était interdit depuis mai les polices
voilà c'est interdit regarde
mesdemoiselles vous montrer sur scène
dans quelques instants le tableau au
cabaret alors comment sarah comment vous
sentez-vous pas très triste et un petit
peu stressé mais on est prêt à vous
faire un bon show et vous me suis libéré
les tout va bien tout va très bien on
est très content d'être ici et je pense
que ça va être un show d'exception
alors on retrouve les miss qui sont
encore en train de se préparer ou alors
on l'a vu alors ça ça fait énormément
parler
est-ce que vous pensez que le csa
d'intervenir que simon oui je pense à
oui c'est ça va un peu choquer il ya une
quarantaine on peut l'enlever 1 derrière
assez bon merci de plainte
et même si c'est une erreur mais même si
la chaîne s'est excusé même si c'est le
direct alors faut savoir qu'il ya eu
trois minutes de faux directs de
décalage ça donc il n'était pas vraiment
en direct mais faut donc qu'ils auraient
pu rectifier à cause d'hier ait pu
rectifier mais je me suis renseigné
n'ont pas eu le temps de réagir
suffisamment vite malgré ses trois
minutes mais ils ont voulu effectivement
intervenir mais oui le sapin intervenir
qu'en prenant quand même comme bémol le
fait que ça soit du semis direct alors
c'est pas vraiment du direct donc l'âme
il ne rien dire je vais vous ne saviez
pas qu'il n'était pas en direct
moi je découvre quelque chose vous
voulez sur les réseaux sociaux pendant
la soirée des comptes twitter reviennent
en direct sur des émissions avec des
petites vidéos de quelques secondes et
c'était le cas de la cérémonie miss
france
il ya par exemple super a peur et ils
ont ils ont fait supprimer son compte
tf ils ont fait supprime également le
compte twitter de télé
deere a également été suspendu après
avoir repris cette séquence c'est
puisque vous ça vous a choqué cette
séquence pas ça m'a choqué dans le sens
où je m'identifie déjà elle parce qu'on
est en train de voir si les spectateurs
surtout pour elle choquée mais ce sont
d'abord elle à première vue parce que
c'est vrai que parfois ce sont eux aussi
un concours qui peut leur faire mettre
dans la tête qu'elles sont à disposition
etc on n'interroge pas les consentements
je sais plus et quelle miss france qui a
témoigné récemment que quand elle
faisait le tour de france et die avait
des mères sans mauvais jeu de mots
filles se sentent est autorisé à aller
toucher en transgressant complet lors
complètement leur consentement
et c'est vrai que ça ça vient d'une
friture on al'impression qu'avec
finalement quelque part elle n'existe
pas un peu les chine mais on peut les
toucher et c'est important qu'elles
s'imposent quand quelque chose et contre
leur consentement et voilà que ce sont
des personnes à part entière et pas
seulement des objets de reprise c'est la
cérémonie miss france qui vous dérange
ou c'est ce dont cette séquence n'a pas
particulièrement bon là c'est rémy ne la
cérémonie miss france c'est vrai que
encore une fois elle montre une certaine
définition de la féminité
alors que quand on est en société on
sait qu'il ya plein de femmes qui s'y
identifie pas en paix être une femme
avec divers morphologie avec différents
âges avec l'incisif du loto il ya en
fait ça reste très cadré même s'il ya
une certaine diversité pesant plus mais
ça reste très cadré il ya même des
femmes assez androgyne tatoué
c'est bien ce que je dis c'est que c'est
encore très cadré c'est que même pas
seulement dans le physique mais aussi
dans l'attitude ce sourire là cette
pause là qui pour moi mais elles savent
en se présentant à ce genre de concours
s avoir fait ça n'empêche pas en fait
que ça a des effets dans la revue
science et pas juste quelque chose quand
c'est pas le concours miss france c'est
la pub qu'on sait pas la pub c'est des
magazines féminins il quand même des
petites filles dans notre société je
vais vous le dire qu'il justifie dernier
qui s'identifie mais aussi qui complexe
qui peut être de l'armée estime de soi
qui peuvent avoir même des comportements
à risque notamment alimentaires parce qu
elle en précisant qu'un corps standard
et ça c'est ce qu'on voit à la télé ce
qui est inatteignable donc s'il faut en
moi qui ait une diversité parce que la
nature encore heureux a prévu une
diversité de morphologie c'est pas ça le
corps par des oeufs des faisans moi je
suis d'accord je suis entière juste
la polémique très vite on a deux minutes
pour agir gilles verdez oui moi je
trouve ça scandaleux
et franchement à force de vouloir faire
du buzz en allant en coulisses on prend
tous les risques
donc on a méprisé les miss ils avaient
tous à l'année dernière je trouve que le
réalisateur à traire alors série lg
comme c'est un ami en plus et franca qui
réalise souvent les mairies qui est
excellent alors cette image me mets à la
place de ces jeunes filles
oui ça me choque bien sûr moi je sais
des jeunes filles elles vont elles vont
rentrer dans leurs facs tout le monde
c'est un des deux qui l'a fait mal oui
il a très mal vécu ça chez le oui est ce
que christine il cesse et non maîtrise
de l'antenne oui ça c'est nous maîtrise
de l'antenne absolument donc peut-être
un peu être attaqué par le cessez le feu
est attaqué par le solide défense cissé
personnellement surtout s'il récidive si
c'est une première depuis très mal en
moi qu'ils vont dire la vérité me
réjouis pas du tout et se sont excusés
du malheur des autres oui mais bon on
est aussi on sait que plus c'est plein
de fois mais je me réjouis pas du tout
du malheur des autres et je pense
franchement que les erreurs ça arrive à
tout le monde franck il a fait une
erreur il est exceptionnel franck et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est une erreur
c'est vrai que pour les miss les deux
les deux qui ont été touchés c'est vrai
que c'est regrettable mais il faut pas
tomber sur tf1 faut pas tomber sur le
réalisateur faut pas tomber sur la
cérémonie miss france c'est une petite
erreur qui est arrivé une seule fois
franchement je pense qu'on peut on peut
les laisser tranquille ce que je vois
beaucoup de gens qui dit voilà il faut
saisir le csa
il faut que sanctionner tf1 ne s'agit
pas du tout pour la santé moi je déteste
les gens qui disent il faut sanctionner
il faut baoji pas laisser ces faits là
et si c'était sur ce plan et la bad
espère que les choses auraient dit il le
ferait pour nous il vous le faire pour
les eaux alors c'est parce qu'elles sont
les autres chaînes parce que
généralement sa chaîne avec le tf est
loin devant
ils essaient de choper wallace en
prennent plein la gueule voilà nous on
n'est pas dans sa série moi quand j'ai
un problème je vais les voir directement
et il se cache dans leurs bureaux est-ce
que les départs de naïfs à penser que ce
soit arrivé totalement par hasard moi
excusez jadis connaît le réalisateur
l'arrivée par hasard
la pierre sur le réalisateur jeudi qu'à
un moment donné c'est peut-être aussi
tf1 qui s'est dit peut-être qu'on peut
mettre nord voilà il y avait rendez vous
avec les amis c'est un choix la base si
tu mets une caméra dans une loge 7h30
qui est responsable de la caméra
d'accord c'est un choix qu'on sujet du
rejet des dix produits pour le boss
c'est ça donc il vaut mieux prendre
moins de risques dans exactement mais
est ce que vous vous êtes pour une
sanction vous que six mois nos idiots
c'est ça je suis pour une sanction s'ils
ont déjà récidiver si c'est pas la
première fois d'accord mais une sanction
et vous c'est un mauvais choix sur ouï
oui parce que ça n'est jamais arrivé
depuis ma longue carrière parce que vous
ne laissez pas faire les rats dans les
crises et n'essaie pas de caméras dans
les coulisses conseillez-vous c'était
vous qui est à la tête de miss france
bonsoir
[Rires]